Pinwheel the necromancer who stole the power of a Gravelord.
A mother, a child and a father
all fused into one form.
His tale is one of guilt, regret
and a desperate desire to fix his mistakes.
Death masks are mementos of the
dead representing the wearer before
they passed away.
Mask of the Father: this mask
belonging to the valiant father
represents great burden and equipment load.
The father made a mistake
and he carries that burden with him.
It's literally a constant weight upon
him.
Mask of the Child:
this mask belonging to the naive child
represents the limitless energy and
stamina of youth.
Mask of the Mother:
this mask belonging to the kindly
mother
represents the life giver and her
vitality.
A long time ago, something happened to this family
and they were brought together through necromancy.
The father bears the weight of his wife and his child on his back.
A family woven together to become
Pinwheel.
It seems as if in another time long past the human mother and child died
tragically and the father was overcome by grief.
Without family, it is said that man is
alone in the world.
But he was valiant and in his
desperation to be reunited with his family
he took great risk to steal power from a Lord of Death: Nito.
With this power he attempted necromancy
reviving the corpses of his wife and
child...
But something went wrong.
In his desperation to be reunited with
his family,
his necromancy backfired and the family
became... Whole.
A mother, child and father
reunited in a physical grotesque form: Pinwheel
In his current form, Pinwheel resides in the crypt filled with his tireless efforts at necromancy and revival.
The creature is still sane and continues to devote itself to experimentation and research into necromancy.
But why?
While the corpses of the mother and child were restored,
but at what cost?
They live on as an abomination.
The only thing  Pinwheel has managed to do so far is split itself into various forms,
which are dumped and discarded at the entrance to Nito's tomb.
Assumedly, Pinwheel is trying to split
itself into separate beings so that
the Father, the Mother and the Child
can be properly restored as was
originally intended.
But nothing works...
For some reason, his crypt is open when you meet him.
Imagine how shocked he must be to see an intruder after all these years.
Someone who would interfere with his
attempt to make things right.
Who knows how close he was to success.
How close he was to fixing his mistake...